tenemos la siguiente ecuación con valor
absoluto 5 que multiplica el valor
absoluto de x 3 hasta que acaba el valor
absoluto menos 3 igual a 7 y bueno
seguramente cuando tienes una ecuación
con valor absoluto tú te sientes un poco
intimidado o tal vez algo desalentado
porque tiene el valor absoluto sin
embargo no hay que preocuparnos tanto
qué te parece si lo primero que hacemos
es aislar la parte que tiene que ver con
valor absoluto vamos a dejar de un lado
de la ecuación esta parte que tiene que
ver con el valor absoluto vamos a
aislarlo mientras que todo lo que no
tenga que ver con el valor absoluto
vamos a pasarlo del otro lado y para
aislar esto pues lo primero que hay que
hacer es quitar este menos 3 y como voy
a sumar 3 de ambos lados de la ecuación
más tres más tres y entonces que me va a
quedar bueno
aquí tengo cinco veces el valor absoluto
de x + 3 5 veces el valor absoluto de x
+ 3 menos tres más tres pero menos tres
más tres se cancelan esto se puede ir
entonces vámonos esto es igual a 73 lo
cual es 10 y ya empezamos poco a poco a
aislar todo lo que tiene que ver con el
belgrado absoluto ya paso a paso lo
estamos dejando cada vez más
y de hecho te das cuenta lo único que me
falta es quitar este 5 que tengo aquí a
la izquierda y para quitarlo lo que voy
a hacer es dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre 5 este lado de la
ecuación entre 5 y que me quedan 5 veces
algo entre 5 pues esto se cancela 5 por
algo y después lo divido entre 5 pues
cinco y cinco se van entonces solamente
me quedaría el 'albo' que en este caso
es el valor absoluto de x 3 el valor
absoluto de x 3 es igual a 10 entre 5 y
10 entre 52 y perfecto date cuenta que
ya dejamos solo lo que tiene que ver con
el valor absoluto de un lado de la
ecuación ya aislamos mientras que el
otro lado de la ecuación ya no tenemos
nada que tenga que ver con valor
absoluto solamente tenemos un 2 y por lo
tanto bueno pues ahora vamos a resolver
esta ecuación como andor absoluto que es
más parecida a la que ya habíamos visto
fíjate bien si yo tengo que el valor
absoluto de algo es igual a 2 pues este
algo podría ser 2 el valor absoluto de
232 es decir que x más 3 podría ser
igualados porque sí que es más 3 fuera 2
cuando le toma el valor absoluto pues
esto me da 2
esta es una posibilidad porque también
fíjate que el valor absoluto de menos 2
también es 2 recuerda que la función
valor absoluto lo que hace es mandarte
los números negativos o positivos
multiplicando los por un menos entonces
menos por menos 2 me da 2 positivo y si
el valor absoluto de menos 2 también los
2 también podría ser entonces que x + 3
fuera igual a menos 2 porque si es más 3
fuera igual a menos 2 le quedaría el
valor absoluto de menos 2 y cuando el
absoluto de menos 2 pues éstos es decir
que si nosotros tenemos una ecuación con
valor absoluto tenemos dos posibles
resultados esto ya lo habíamos visto o x
+ 3 es igual a 2 x 3 es igual a menos 2
y de hecho también lo habíamos visto
como la distancia recuerdas el valor
absoluto es pensar en la distancia que
tenemos al cero lo que estamos haciendo
aquí es que numerosos tienen una
distancia de dos unidades para llegar al
cero y bueno pues hay dos valores tener
22 estados unidades del 0 - 2 - 2
también está a dos unidades del cero por
lo tanto si lo vemos como distancia
estamos diciendo que x 3
puede ser dos o en todo caso también
puede ser menos dos y bueno pues ahora
vamos a resolver estas ecuaciones está
muy sencillo si yo restó tres damos la
ecuación me queda que x es igual a
cuanto x más 3 - 3 estos dos se cancelan
y dos menos tres esto es igual a menos
uno en dos me quedaría que x es igual a
dos menos tres lo cual es menos 1 esto
en la primera posibilidad que tenemos y
por lo tanto esta es nuestra primera
solución ahora bien también tenemos que
x más 3 es igual a menos 2 este es
nuestro segundo caso así que de igual
manera voy a restar tres de ambos lados
de la ecuación y me queda x más 3 menos
3 pues esto solamente x y menos 2 menos
3 lo cual es menos 5 ya tenemos nuestra
segunda solución nuestra segunda
respuesta a esta ecuación y por lo tanto
tanto x igual a menos 1 como x igual a
menos 5 ambas son soluciones de esta
ecuación con valor absoluto que de hecho
sería bastante bueno que lo corroboramos
voy a sustituir primero el valor de x
igual a menos 1 y que me va a quedar 5
veces el valor de x más 3 pero x vale
menos 1 es decir cinco veces el valor
absoluto de menos 13
-3 y cuánto es esto vamos a ver si en
efecto nos da 7 menos 13
esto es 2 entonces me quedarían cinco
veces que multiplica el valor absoluto
de dos menos tres este cuento es igual y
bueno pues ahora voy a aplicar el valor
absoluto el valor absoluto de 12 2
entonces me quedaría 5 por 2 - 3 pero 5
por 12 10 - 3 esto es 7 perfecto 10
menos 13 7 y por lo tanto el valor de x
igual a menos uno cumple esta ecuación
ahora vamos a hacer la prueba vamos a
ver si realmente funciona también para
la otra solución x igual a menos 5 y me
quedaría si sustituyó el valor de x 5
veces que multiplica el valor absoluto
de x + 3 pero x vale menos 5 entonces me
quedaría 5 que multiplica al valor
absoluto de menos 53 menos 3 y cuantos
esto 5 por el valor absoluto de al menos
dos menos tres y ahora vamos a hacer el
valor absoluto el valor absoluto de
menos 2 es 2 también entonces me
quedaría 5 x 2 menos tres lo cual es 10
menos 3 lo cual también es 7 entonces
también se cumple que la solución x 5 al
sustituir la nuestra
original nos da el valor de 7 por lo
tanto x igual a 1 y es igual a menos 5
ambas son soluciones de esta ecuación y
fíjate que todo es bastante congruente
cuando yo metí la solución de morado
obtuve el valor absoluto de 2 porque
había supuesto ax-3 igualdad 2 y cuando
yo metí la solución de verde en la parte
de amarillo llegué al valor absoluto de
menos 2 y esto fue porque había supuesto
que x + 3 será igual al menos 2 y si yo
quisiera graficar estas dos soluciones
déjenme ser de nuevo una recta numérica
voy a poner aquí los dos valores de x
así que voy a suponer que este es el
cero aquí está el 1
aquí está el 2 y para atrás el menos uno
al menos dos el menos tres el -4 el
menos cinco todavía necesito y el -6 y
bueno x igual a menos uno estaría por
aquí y si te das cuenta este es el valor
cuando x vale menos 1 y x igual a menos
5 estaría por acá déjame cambiar de
color
x igual a menos 5 está justo aquí así
que espero que esté encontrado esto
bastante útil